[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] [
Applaudissements]
euh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
leurs actions sont terrifiantes je veux dire
nous en tant que démocratie et euh nous devons nous
lever
j'ai 60 ans je ne devrais probablement pas  être
ici en public
mais c'est au-delà de l'acceptable
et j'ai
donné des signes de paix aux officiers qui
sont sortis
et ont pointé leurs armes sur moi et j'ai dit
que je suis ici avec mon premier amendement
droit de manifester pacifiquement et ils
m'ont quand même tiré dessus avec des centaines de
spray au poivre que je n'ai jamais vu
[  Musique] ce
sont des gaz lacrymogènes et des gens ils
attrapent des gens ils battent
des gens dans les rues
comme ouais ils tirent sur des gens
n'importe où dans le visage avec des balles en caoutchouc
ils sortent les masques des gens et les
aspergent de gaz poivré
comme oui, ça a été assez brutal, c'est
là que nos forces de police nous montrent
exactement ce qu'elles pensent de leurs
citoyens et c'est là que maintenant le
gouvernement fédéral nous montre
exactement comment ils vont essayer de
nous empêcher de faire des changements et c'est
inacceptable
et c'est exaspérant et c'est terrifiant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Je peux vous dire qu'à Portland, ils ont fait
un travail fantastique, ils sont là depuis trois
jours
et ils ont vraiment fait un
travail fantastique en très peu de temps  temps pas de
problème
ils les attrapent beaucoup de gens en prison
ce sont des dirigeants ce sont des anarchistes
ce ne sont pas des manifestants les
gens disent des manifestants ces gens sont des
anarchistes
ce sont des gens qui détestent notre pays
[Musique]
toi